what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with the Hulk yes we are I just
woke up by the way so my voice is deeper
than normal so what this does is this
picks up with Banner in the mind of a
possessed Hulk because as we covered in
the last video The Hulk is currently
possessed by an elder demon right if you
guys need to get caught up on the
current run we're only two videos in
you'll find a link to it at the end of
the playlist so one of the big changes
that was made here is that instead of
Bruce Banner's mind being in this kind
of endless ether whenever the Hulk
Persona takes over that he's actually in
a kind of landscape essentially but once
he gets there he finds these kind of
hyenas devouring this corpse and then
this corpse kind of like emerges and
then it appears as just like a giant
demonic eye right so like Sauron from
Lord of the Rings but it talks about how
basically Banner has no place in the
garden that it's here for the body of
the Hulk now one of the things to know
is that in the last couple videos that
we did a little bit of catch up here for
those of you guys who have fallen behind
is that the Hulk just sort of found
himself in this town which is
essentially being overrun or at least
attacked pretty regularly by a being
called Genie deal and that it is in
effect just this kind of demonic Force
we don't know a whole lot about it we
simply just know that for whatever
reason it essentially seeks to take
control of people and then you know
unleash all kinds of pandemonium and
stuff it feels more like a Ghost Rider
villain than a Hulk villain if I'm being
honest with you guys which is why the
Ghost Rider appearing here just seems so
perfect but for the Hulk himself he had
been taken over at the end of the last
video right he had literally become
possessed and in doing so he's joining
the forces of Genny de gal and running
through and attacking all these
different beings all these different
people that are out there now one of the
things that does happen is Charlie does
try to speak reason again in the last
video we talked about how Charlie is
basically this girl who's just been
joining the Hulk on his bit of an
Escapade so to speak right like they
effectively found themselves as just
kind of unwitting really allies and she
just kind of been with him the whole
time and so Ghost Rider just reemerges
now this Ghost Rider is not the one that
we're traditionally familiar with which
is also what we talked about right this
guy is a dude by the name of s but sa
did not seem to come back as a
traditional Ghost Rider and we'll talk
about why once we get to the end of this
because it solidifies him as being
different from really like Robbie Reyes
or Johnny Blaze or Danny catch or any of
those guys instead he's just kind of
here to protect what is basically his
nephew right like this little kid at
least we assume it's his nephew because
the kid calls him like Uncle s and so
what happens right this really really
cool moment here what happens is
transitioning back to Bruce Banner in
the mind of the Hulk that suddenly the
Hulk personality manifests inside of its
own mind and this is one of those things
where context provides us the answer to
the question that we're asking that it's
not Banner doing it himself that
literally J de Gall who's taken over the
Hulk says No Escape little Locust The
Brute may have been Your Vessel but now
he is mine and the Hulk manifests in
simply saying stupid not Banner's place
not your place my place get out right so
one of the cool things is that you've
also got Banner who's literally kind of
held safe by this you know by this Hulk
manifestation in his own rib cage right
Banner just kind of looks powerless he
has no real clue what's going on but it
is interesting because this is one of
those stories or one of those moments it
could go either way potentially Banner
manifested the Hulk personality which is
kind of his way to protect himself in
this kind of a theal realm whenever he's
not actually The Incredible Hulk in the
real world or it is the Hulk taking
himself over I want to know which one of
you guys think it is you think Banner
did it or Hulk did it I'm kind of
curious where your all's thought process
is but at the exact same moment that
Genie de gal is forced out Hulk comes
back to his senses in the real world and
incapacitates jinny Deal's forces but
also working alongside the Ghost Rider
right jinny to gal manifest and says
fractured son Ghost Rider long and long
has it been no matter I was there when
the first living man entered my garden I
will see the last of you dead each at
the other's hands so this is where
things get kind of murky here because
with the Incredible Hulk no longer being
a war devil Hulk right and just kind of
being an Incredible Hulk as shortlived
as it may have been the nature of Jenny
de gal is still very very ambiguous now
Philip Kennedy Johnson when he initially
created this character created it to be
a representation of PTSD right like this
just kind of trauma that passes quote
unquote from one person to the next
Who's endured war or different things
along those lines which is why those
individuals who were so easily possessed
are those who have endured such harsh
and terrible traumas over the course of
their lives because PTSD is not just
limited to a person who's like been to
war and come back PTSD can manifest
really in the aftermath of any kind of
harrowing situation and the Hulk life is
nothing but a series of harrowing
situations if we're being honest with
ourselves right ghost ride is a little
bit different here and that's where
where things are kind of intriguing but
as far as the actual character and the
concept of Jenny deal the fact that it's
saying things like I was there when the
first living man entered my garden one
either it's as old as mankind or two if
it created any kind of a meaningful
Garden it predates man kind and so this
is potentially an instance where Philip
Kennedy Johnson is creating and
revealing a new Elder God that we didn't
know about before now not all Elder gods
are equal in terms of their power and in
fact most aren't really as powerful as
you would think they are at least not in
comparison to Elder Gods like cathon or
citak or any of the other members of the
octessence right and so on and so forth
why they're powerful in their own right
but they're not like Godly powerful
right not nowhere near as the other guys
but the fact remains here right this is
probably going to be something that will
unfold over time because literally what
ends up happening is that these guys in
one of the coolest moments ever Ghost
Rider says like I ain't been a living
man in a good while and just like breaks
out his flaming chains so seemingly this
guy has all the same abilities as the
traditional ghost riders that we know of
specifically Johnny blae and Danny catch
really Danny catch is the Ghost Rider
you think of when you think of the guy
with a flaming chain Johnny Blaze got it
later but Danny catch was really the one
that made it cool but the thing here is
that with the Hulk and Ghost Rider
working together Ghost Rider is just
firing off these hell bullets right
every chance he gets to try to shoot
this thing the Hulk is just like Ryder
give me your chains Ryder like spins the
chains throws them to the Hulk the Hulk
kind of comments about how strong they
are that these chains are pretty strong
which makes sense right I mean it
wouldn't make a whole lot of sense if
the main weapon of the Ghost Rider
outside of the pennant stair amounted to
having the strength of a toothpick but
literally the Hulk grabs the chain leaps
up into Genie 's mouth punches a hole
through the top of its head and then
they just start wrapping this thing up
with chains and I'll admit man it's
pretty awesome to see the Ghost Rider
and Hell Hulk teaming up together to
destroy this thing like it's pretty
phenomenal but Hulk ultimately ends up
coming down because of course this thing
just had the Hulk jump through its head
and it goes as far as to say eldis will
have you fractured son your flesh is the
key and is hers by right by my eldest
hands the mother of whors will return
and she will grant me my vengeance upon
all man kind and so again another Force
at work here right one that is presiding
over Jenny de gal and another ambiguous
entity right the eldest as far as I'm
aware is a title that's given to like
this race out there that kind of went to
war against the sh for a little bit but
just like another alien race it's more
of like a ceremonial title than an
actual entity I'm sure over time right
Philip Kennedy Johnson will reveal all
the answers to the questions that we
have but it is cool because following
that you have this bit of a discussion
between Ghost Rider and Hulk and this
will set the stage for everything going
forward in the Hulk Comics right Hulk
asks Ghost Rider the question why not
you aren't you one of the eldest to and
the response to the Hulk is I heard her
call sure but I was a ghost riter
disobedience is our whole thing besides
something else brought me back something
that needs that kid safe that's all it
cares about it says that in the world
where he dies everything goes wrong so I
won't let him not here now here's why
That Matters by and large Ghost Riders
like Danny catch and Johnny Blaze are
really the result of Mesto Robbie Reyes
is the result of an actual demon but
it's usually Mesto that is responsible
for the creation of Ghost Riders and not
even just those guys right but basically
any Ghost Rider going back to the early
days of the Ghost Rider's first
existence and even alternate reality
Ghost Riders right like uh Cosmic Ghost
Rider right Frank Castle becoming that
character that was because of Mesto so
it's almost always attributed to Mesto
there's never really been an instance
outside of Robbie Reyes where we've seen
some other entity out there create a
Ghost Rider and imbue it with all the
powers that a Ghost Rider has but Mao's
goals and Ambitions are usually murky at
best right I mean he's a bad guy who
does bad things but sometimes he does
good things or things that appear to be
good in order to achieve a goal in this
instance it could be one of those
situations where this kid will be like
the one thing that stops some guy from
attaining some level of power that would
not only allow that person to conquer
the world but also like conquer the
entirety of the universe or wipe the
whole universe out or any number of
things right mephisto's realm is part of
the main Marvel Universe if the universe
is destroyed his realm goes with it now
whether that's the case or not we don't
know like we literally have no idea it
could be that this is some entity that's
not even tied into misto right like
Philip Kennedy Johnson is introducing
the idea that someone out there Beyond
any kind of helll Lord created a Ghost
Rider which would be cool right but the
other thing that the Ghost Rider says is
your weak spot is the girl and he says
you're a tough kill if the eldest does
not get that yet she soon will she'll
get to you through the girl keep her
safe Hulk in the end she'll be the one
that matters right so what kind of
setting the stage for the fact that the
Hulk is basically going to be the
protector of Charlie but something is
going to happen the eldest will appear
and when that happens who knows what's
going to take place I'm really really
curious is this the strongest Hulk story
that I've ever read no and it's not the
strongest Hulk run that I've seen but I
am excited to see where Philip Kennedy
Johnson goes he never disappoints but
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end if you guys need to
get caught up make sure you click this
link to the playlist and I will catch
you all later peace